i don't even want to talk about pelosi
please don't open that uh
we're not doing that nancy pelosi is
probably an example of
sometimes you need to
sometimes the world changes without you
and it's not even just her i think
that's just the way the policies are on
capitol hill they're antiquated
[Music]
i think there's got to be a change over
here when uh uh we're left with uh for
dead over here on the streets over here
and and all the storefront owners and
all the cars are getting broken into
there's got to be a change everybody
knows this and all you have to do is
come on out here and then not only ask
me ask everybody else and see what
they're saying if you got a lot of these
politicians that have been politicians
for so long we don't know where none of
their money comes from when you see net
worth i don't even want to get in
trouble because this is some stuff i
didn't research that's crazy but it's a
lot of these folks who network that
double and triple if she does run again
even though people don't change there's
going to have to be a lot of change
there's gonna have to be a lot of change
because right now it seems like there's
uh
autocratic leadership going on i mean
for my people that's from oakland like
me the ghost ride in the country right
now there should be an age limit
with politicians in general
whether they're good or bad because just
you know get to a point where you're
kind of
outdated on the times and you've been in
the position so long where you're kind
of stuck in your own ways
so
maybe she should retire i'm more by the
people for the people if i see more
people of color coming into
positions of power then i'll be more
happy and appreciative of it i mean
she's probably well qualified i just
hope she can remember everything i mean
i'm 53 this month and i'm forgetting
stuff
so you know hopefully uh she can retain
her memory but at the end of the day i'm
looking around my own country all the
time and we got messes to fix here all
the time but we're sending money
everywhere
you know
you know so that's hard for me
you